人家不想跟你好好过日子，是因为人家在跟你过日子的过程当中，人家感受不到经济的透明啊。人家钱都交到你手上，你现在手上分没有没有存款呢？人家想问问钱花到哪里去了之后，你就觉得啊，他不爱我了，他不在乎我，他不信任我了。因为之前连过一个情感主播，然后就被凯骂我下去了。先说一下大概情况，我老公、我对象是我不知道能不能说就是军穿那个绿色衣服的，他是现役的是吗？我们是在一起8年时间就谈恋爱，大概4年结婚大概4年。我们是21年2月份左右结的。她家里的话，就剩我婆婆一个人了，就是公公不在了，婆婆是没有工资没有收入的，但是她现在也在工作，可能一个月就是能挣个一两千左右是这样子，我们因为一些事情就是吵架了。现在已经是冷静期的最后几天了。之前吵架的话，总是因为钱的事情，几乎每年都会因为钱的这个事情吵，就是他的工资是都交给我的，所以这个事情他可能不是很乐意。我们最后一次吵的话，是他觉得工资都交给我，说我钱都花到哪里去了，但是实际上他工资是1.2左右一个月。我们房贷就是我婚前有一个小房子，Loft, 每个月大概还2600左右。
是我的名字，还有也是婚前买的，都为了结婚才买的。就结婚前一段时间买的也是我的名字。因为他的户口的问题，没有办法写他的名字。然后，那个房子的话，之前最早的时候是7000左右的房贷，也就是说，两个房子加在一起，刚开始是9000左右的房贷，所以他大部分工资是还了房贷了。我的工资是用于我们正常花销的，他现在就是因为这个事情想离婚的话，我想问一下这个房子该怎么分自己工作吗？我工作的大概收入一个月是多少钱呀？我是1.5左右。房子的首付是怎么组成的？首付的话，他家里当时掏了十个，他借了十七八个，然后首付是54万左右。他借了十七八个，然后给我父母打了一个15万的欠条，剩下的钱全部都是我垫的。他当时给了一个8万的彩礼，但是那个彩礼里面有3万是我自己垫进去的，因为5万太少了我我担心父母，因为父母是不同意我们两个结的，我就自己用自己的钱给了他3万，给我父母总共给了8万。然后买房的时候，又把这些钱又重新垫回去了。现在主要是说男方想跟你分开，是不是我觉得是这样，但现在马上就要到时间了。我们是6月初的时候去登记的，登记的。
李业到现在他还不给我协议，你俩没有孩子，对是的，你俩从领证到现在多长时间了？21年2月领的，差不多4年，这四年时间，人家男方的工资都交给你了。对，是的，因为婚前发生了一些可能不太信任的一些事情，所以工资的话是都给我的。我给他开亲情付，他每次也是可以用的。那男方之所以跟你要提分开，主要的矛盾是什么？在最后一次我们吵这个事情的时候，是在4月份左右时间。然后在4月份左右的时候，我们还在商量，就是要小孩这个事情都去检查了身体因为一个小事儿吵了架之后，他就又提到钱了。我去翻聊天记录，就发现之前每年都会因为这个工资花到哪里去了，钱到哪里去了？这个事情去吵架，我问你啊，你看他四年都把工资交给你了。你四年当中的话，你也收入挺高的。你一个月一万五，最近一年左右是1.5。之前的话，基本是五六千，大部分时间。那现在你手上有多少存款呢？没有存款，全是负债。那人家问你钱花到哪里去了？这不是应该的吗？因为我们都是两个房子装修，还有我们两个共同生活，花掉了，就是我家在我结婚的这个期间，给我转了大概76个，你家还给你转了76万。对，然后现在你手上一分没有对，是的。
我算了一下，应该是负债，因为他结婚买房的时候是借的钱。我刚才说过了，我这两三年基本都是用家里给的这个钱，还有我们攒的这个钱，全部都还给他，就是帮他还了多少外债，有数吗？全还了，总共还了多少钱？有数没数？借的18左右全还了。那你装修花了多少钱？我的loft装修花了大概是15往上吧，现在这个房子花了将近30个，你现在想要问我的问题该怎么分这个财产是吗？首先，第1个是我不太想离婚的，因为我家里付出了这么多的情况，就是我不管底下这些评论也分不清到底是谁付出的多或者付出的少。但是我肯定是奔着不离婚的情况下，才会接收到娘家给我转的这些大笔的金额去填补我们小家的。但是他如果确定要离我也不会说是强迫或者逼他。我现在的意思就是因为我们马上就要到时间了，如果这个协议没有达成的情况下，那是确定可以先办理离婚的吗？你俩去分手的话，肯定是要有一个协议的，除非你俩自己愿意说我俩只是现在协议把婚离了，然后我俩没有任何共同财产，没有任何财产纠纷。你俩要是白纸黑字这么写了，去离是可以的，但是你觉得。
男方同意吗？男方这不是之所以现在没有达成协议，是因为还不知道你该补人家多少钱吗？对，就是他也说他去找那个律师去算，但是到今天我们可能还有一周左右时间就不能再领了。你是问我你的那个房子该怎么算？是不是对我现在主要是想问分开的这个事情怎么分开？因为我咨询了好多人，他们意思就是现在钱的问题不是最主要的，最主要的是，如果他反悔不那个什么的怎么办？如果他反悔不愿意分开的话，你没有办法，你分不了，你打官司也打不了，就不行，是吗？对，所以这事儿，你肯定是占弱势的。所以人家如果想分开，你问问人家想要多少钱的补偿。但是我家里已经把钱全部都垫进去了，然我给他钱，我可以卖两个。卖的话，他都是会折钱的，就相当于我家掏的这些钱全部都折进去了。他意思就是，反正你嫁底以后不怕赔的，反正折的话也是我折的多。所以我现在也不知道该怎么。其实，你就算一下，他总共付出了多少钱。他结婚之前举个例子啊，他结婚之前为这个房子，他付出去那个钱，你不是已经给他还掉了吗？还掉的钱就不算了。咱们算就是他真金白银就刨出去那些还掉的钱之外，他真金白银，他付出了多少钱？他家的10万和他。
这几年还的房贷，其他没有任何是他付出的了，剩下都是我付出，这是10万，加上他这些年还的房贷，大概是40万，对不对？50多万吧，因为一个月大概房贷就少1万块钱，少1万块钱那样加起来的话，咱们就算是60万，这60万的话，那你也得有策略。你说是看上去的话，你为这个房产总共付出了60万，但是我也为这个家庭付出了生活开销啊，这个家庭要运作呀，要有物业费啊，有水电费啊，我也付出了。所以我给你打个折，比如打什么折呢，我给你40万，照理来说的话，你为这个房子付出的房贷也属于夫妻共同财产，我也能分一半呀。但是我给你打个折，比如说我退你40万，咱俩好聚好散行不行，就是你觉得就是我这边是还要给他付事十是吗？按照道理来说的话啊，你俩如果要分开了，他要分的话，他只能分什么呢？分他还贷那一部分的一半，比如说他总共还贷还了50万，那他能分走25万，他婚前的那10万块钱也要给人家折抵一部分的，婚前的那10万块钱也要给人家折抵一部分的，所以这样加起来的话，他大概啊，我觉得至少得分个30多万。我的意思是因为人家身份特殊，你想要跟人家好聚好散的话，得人家同意。人家不同意的话，人家拖着你的话，给你拖到35，给你拖到40，他不害怕他。
40岁了，他正当年他随便找是吧，咱40岁了，咱就麻烦了呀。如果我们不愿意被别人拖到那个境地的话，我愿意在经济上，哎我多给你一点，就举个例子，就本来照理来说的话，假设他打官司，他能分走30多万，那好，我给你40万，咱俩就好聚好散，是这么个意思啊。就是我现在就可能只能卖了房子之后，但是我现在这个房子如果卖了的话，可能是折钱的。如果折钱的话，把银行的贷款还掉之后，你单是不剩什么钱，然后去给他分的那要不你就再拖一拖，没准拖完了之后，人家那头没找到合适的，又找你复合呢，这不也有可能吗？可是他现在不愿意还房贷，就不愿意给我生活费，什么都不愿意给我的，就按我现在的情况，你要么就是说你求和是吧？你把这个经济账算明白了，你说我俩如果要分开的话，我愿意给你多少补偿？你求和呀，你看人家愿不愿意跟你过呀？如果人家实在不愿意跟你过了，人家不给你钱，这不很正常吗？房子又在你名下，又不在他名下，他不给你钱，这不很正常吗？但是房子他也是能分得到的，其实算起来人家是亏的，为什么是亏的呢？他这些年的工资都给你了，他一年的工资16万是吧，没有那么多。他毕业了就去我们结的婚，他毕业的时候一个月就七八千，然后结婚这大概三四年的话，是一万到一万二，不管怎么说。
那么这些年人家的工资都交给你了啊，人家这工资交给你了，这四年的婚姻本额算下来的话，也得有50万对不对？嗯，人家这50万交给你了，然后人家婚前又给了彩礼，又给了10万块钱买房的钱是不是加起来是65万？人家这65万人家要跟你分开的话，人家只能可能分三十几万，是不是人家也亏了，就我没有觉得我亏不亏的问题？就是我现在想的是，如果他不愿意离我是一点办法都没有的是吗？你没有任何办法，他只要不愿意离，因为有别的律师跟我讲说可以起诉的话是可以的。他是现役的，对他是现役的，只要他不同意离，你死都离不掉。这几年就是我人也没得到啊，钱也没有得到，因为都还了房贷了嘛，他的工资都在房子里了。你这想法是不对的。为什么房子在你名下？就是我在意的不是房子。我要房子是为了跟他好好过日子的。可是他现在因为钱不想跟我好好过日子。人家不想跟你好好过日子，是因为人家在跟你过日子的过程当中，人家感受不到经济的透明啊，人家钱都交到你手上，你现在手上分没有没有存款呢？人家想问问钱花到哪里去了之后，你就觉得啊，他不爱我了，他不在乎我，他不信任我了。问我钱花在哪里去了的时候，我给他算账了，我不会说是把那什么吃了喝了他每次休假过来玩。
了或者怎么样的钱去跟他算，但是我会给他算大账。就比如说结完婚之后拍婚纱照，因为他公司都交了房贷，没有钱，婚纱照这些都是我掏的，旅游我掏的，然后看演唱会什么我掏的这些大账我会算他小账，我没有去算。然后他做手术啊什么的我也都给他算大账了。加上两三年，我们装修房子花了大概五六十个，然后还有就是给他同学还的十七八个，这些账都是能对得上的。我虽然没有存下钱，但是我没有说是花他的钱。他认为的是他把钱还了房贷，所以导致我把我的工资都挥霍了。但是不是这样的，就虽然我比较爱网购什么的可能没有存下钱，但是我们两个共同生活，包括交物业费、水电费这些东西也都是我一个人承担的。我把大账是可以给他算的明白，算的清楚，也说的明白。并不是说不能让他算，或者不能让他问。那你就给他算明白，给他说清楚这钱花到哪里去了。我说清楚了，但是他好像是就听不进去了。就我们上最后一次吵架，就他一直说我花了他的钱，为什么需要我帮你解决的问题呢？他如果不理也不还贷款的话，我该怎么办呢？你只能自己还，我只能自己还，不然的话就容易上黑名单。如果我没有能力呢，因为我现在在杭州这边没有能力，到最后房产就会被拍卖。
没有啊，这种情况的话，拍卖掉损失大还是卖掉算是大，定是拍卖损失大，通常情况下，假设一套房子在市场上能卖100万的话，走拍卖程序的话，可能能卖到70万，或者说75万，大概就这样了，行吧，我知道你有没有能力挽回这段感情。第二，如果你没有能力挽回这段感情的话，他想分开，那正好，借着这个由头卖一套房子，看给他多少钱，咱们好聚好散，就分开了。第三，如果说他那一头也觉得这个钱给的不合适，他要拖你的话，那你是占劣势，他是占优势啊。我明白了，拜拜啊，好，谢谢，拜拜。有这个案例啊，我直播间的工作人员给我记一下，优先给我剪出来，给我优先发，为什么呢？我就想为自己证个明，谁说我破坏军婚来着？谁说我对军哥哥不友好来着？谁说我对军哥哥有敌意来着？像今天的这个军哥哥，是不是人家没没没有我什么也没有。人家挣了钱都交到女方手里了，那你能听出来我的这种感情倾向了吗？但凡是兵哥哥，别别。
别打人，别在外面，就是欠乱七八糟一堆烂债的话，我永远占。你们真的都去给我点关注。